♪
THERE IT IS, NEWS IN FOR
HUNTER'S ART CAREER.
THE FORMER OBAMA ETHICS CHIEF
TEARING INTO THE SON'S PLAN TO
SELL HIS PAINTINGS FOR PRICES UP
TO A HALF MILLION.
THAT'S ONE OF THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NOTION OF THE PRESIDENT'S SON
CAPITALIZING ON THAT
RELATIONSHIP BY SELLING ART AT
OBVIOUSLY INFLATED PRICES AND
KEEPING THE PUBLIC IN THE DARK
ABOUT WHO IS FUNNELING MONEY TO
HIM HAS A SHAMEFUL FEEL TO IT.
HUNTER IS NOT THE ONLY FAMILY
MEMBER CASHING IN.
RELATIVES OF KEY WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS HAVE LANDED JOBS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT GENERAL
PSAKI SAYS THERE IS NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT.
>> WE HAVE THE HIGHEST ETHICAL
STANDARDS AS ANY ADMINISTRATION
IN HISTORY.
A NUMBER OF ETHICS OFFICIALS
HAVE CONVEYED THAT AND WE'RE
PROUD OF THAT.
>> JEN, COULD YOU ARGUE THAT
HUNTERS'S PAINTINGS ARE DESIGNED
TO KEEP HIS NOSE CLEAN.
THAT'S WHY HE USES STRAWS --
>> I LOVE DOING BLOW ART.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DID.
AS A KILLED.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
AT VACATION BIBLE SCHOOL.
WE WOULD DO THAT.
SO MUCH FUN.
>> WHAT DID YOU DO IN VACATION
BIBLE SCHOOL?
YOU WENT TO VACATION --
>> I DID, TOO.
>> WE'RE THE WEIRDOES HERE,
JESSE.
.
>> SOMETIMES CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS,
EASTER HOLIDAYS.
A WEEK WHERE YOU GO TO LIKE A
CAMP EVERY DAY, VACATION BIBLE
SCHOOL AND YOU GET TO DO LIKE
CRAFT AND ACTIVITIES.
>> AND LEARN THE BEATITUDES.
>> MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE GONE TO
THAT.
>> I THINK THERE IS A HOLE IN MY
LIFE.
>> VACATION BIBLE SCHOOL WAS
AWESOME.
THE LAST THICK I'LL -- THING
I'LL SAY ON THIS, RESPONDING
INDIGNANTLY, IS KIND OF IRONIC
GIVEN THAT THEY REALLY RAN
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP BASED ON
HIS ETHICS.
>> HOW QUICKLY THEY FORGET,
DANA.
HOW QUICKLY THEY FORGET.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH SELLING ART
BASED ON YOUR NOTORIETY?
ISN'T THAT KIND OF LIKE AN
AUTOGRAPH?
>> NO, IF YOUR FATHER IS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND YOU HAVE A
HISTORY OF QUESTIONABLE, AT THE
VERY LEAST, BEHAVIOR, A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO NOBODY EVEN KNEW THIS
LOSER WAS AN ARTIST UNTIL THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE THIS
GLOWING PROFILE OF HIM, JUST AS
THE PANDEMIC WAS TAKING OFF.
AS THEY WON A PULITZER FOR
CORONAVIRUS COVERAGE.
THERE IS A NEW ARTIST IN TOWN
AND HIS NAME IS BIDEN.
THEY TALK ABOUT, OH, PAINT STAIN
FOREARMS AND FINGERS, AND THE
BLACK AND RED DEEP UNDER HIS
NAILS.
SO NOW HE'S SELLING THESE THINGS
OR TRYING TO FOR HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS.
I WOULD SAY, OF THAT PRICE, 90%
IS BRIBERY.
MAYBE 10% IS FOR THE PAINT.
NOBODY NOW IS GOING TO BUY THIS
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
THEIR BACKGROUND LOOKED INTO.
LIKE THEY ARE GOING TO GET A
RING A DING-DING FOR THE FBI OR
JUSTICE.
>> MAYBE HE SNEAKS COKE INTO THE
CANVASS.
A GREAT WAY TO GET IT OVER THE
POROUS BORDER.
RICHARD, THE ONE THING ABOUT
NEPOTISM WE CAN AGREE ON IS THAT
IT HURTS MINORITIES.
YOU'RE ALREADY LAUGHING.
>> HOW DID MINORITIES GET INTO
THIS?
>> BECAUSE WHITE PEOPLE HAVE THE
JOBS THAT THEY CAN JUST HIRE
THEIR CRONIES' KIDS.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NEPOTISM.
MINORITIES ARE HURT MOST BY
NEPOTISM BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THE
POWER STRUCTURE TO GIVE THE JOBS
TO THEIR KIDS AND FRIENDS.
>> THINK OF THE IOWA BILL.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, I DON'T
THINK THAT HUNTER SHOULD BE
SELLING HIS PAINTERS.
IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THERE IS
STILL A PENDING JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION THAT'S GOING ON,
UNHARMED -- WHICH SPEAKS TO THE
FACT THAT JOE BIDEN BELIEVES IN
THIS IDEAL OF AN INDEPENDENT
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S HAPPENING.
THAT BEING SAID IT'S ALSO WORTH
POINTING OUT THERE ARE NO BIDEN
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE WHITE
HOUSE UNLIKE THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE WHERE EVERYBODY --
>> THE POINT WAS, THERE ARE A
FEW PEOPLE WHO ARE APPOINTED IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT OFTEN HAPPENS.
YOU MEET IN WASHINGTON.
YOU STAY IN WASHINGTON.
>> SWAMP.
>> WHEN I COINED THE PHRASE
SWAMP THAT'S WHAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
WE NEED TO DRAIN THE SWAMP.
>> JESSE, I DON'T KNOW IF
SELLING ART IS A BAD THING
BECAUSE I HAVE A FEELING YOU AND
I WILL BE DOING THIS IN THE NEXT
10 YEARS.
>> WE'LL BE DOING BLOW --
>> BLOW ART.
>> OR VACATION BIBLE SCHOOL WE
SHOULD PROBABLY DO BOTH.
>> ONE BEFORE THE OTHER.
DO YOU CONSIDER ME A PETTY
FEELING.
>> PERHAPS.
>> WOULD YOU MIND IF I ACT A
LITTLE PETTY?
>> PLEASE DO.
>> LAST WEEK I SAID ON THIS SHOW
THAT HUNTER SELLING HIS BLOW
ART, I DON'T KNOW TO A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE FOR HALF A MILLION
WAS VIOLATING THE SPIRIT OF
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND POTENTIAL,
I DON'T KNOW, LAUNDERING LAWS,
BRIBERY STATUES, WHATEVER, DID
IT MAKE WAVES?
NO.
THE ETHICS EXPERT FOR JOE BIDEN
SAID IT AND EVERYONE GOES, OH,
REALLY, PERHAPS WE SHOULD LOOK
INTO THIS.
EXPERTS REALIZE THIS IS A SCAM.
DIE NEED A NEW TITLE?
IS FOX HOST NOT ENOUGH FOR
PEOPLE TO PAY ATTENTION.
I MEAN, DO I HAVE TO GO TO LAW
SCHOOL FOR PEOPLE TO LISTEN TO
ME.
IT'S CLEARLY A SCAM.
WHY DOES AN EXPERT HAVE TO TELL
YOU, I SAID IT.
>> LOOK AT THOSE PAINTINGS.
YOU REALIZE THAT IT LOOKS LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW --
>> I WAS WAITING FOR HIM TO
THROW ONE UP THERE.
IT LOOKS LIKE A LEFTOVER FROM